three
um
oh hello
hello hi i'm lauren lamkin i am
all of job can i am relaxed
know your night sky which one of
you i am wearing i'm scott this
is my real voice learn what is
your real voice this
no is your real voice like a
voice that you learn to do my
real voice is just what comes out
no but i'm i'm using no no
no but like is your real voice
yours at your jacket voice and now
you owe and you haven't had to
grow up with an accent i only
have an accent on certain words as
you've experienced i don't think i ever
worked to not have that
in jackets is that your jacket is
um and is yeah nah ah some
things are a little midwestern but i
don't really work to go again but
don't you sort of you don't you
just like what what would your normal
speaking voice be because do you sometime
was put on sort of more of
ah i do think with certain people
i find myself doing something like anyone
just sort of being like i'm
oh nice i thank you so
i talking to a black person like
hey man
i'm i'm going to respond hey my
man hey my brother what's um bites
do you change your voice yeah i
think we everyone changes their voices depending
on we all code switch all of
us what called really code switch yeah
code switching is is sort of like
um you know in in the african-american
community it's like the the
you use for work vs the voice
you're hanging up c o c sorry
to bother you i do want to
see that movie i do want to
um
i grew up with an accent i
had a philadelphia acts like what does
that um you yeah you you you
doing philadelphia's the only time i've ever
realized what a philadelphia accent is he'll
do it in a second but then
since then i've seen people on the
news and i've been like news yeah
i've been like that accent sounds weird
to be let me look up if
they're from philadelphia and it's that's what
it is anytime i hear yeah right
okay so do do locus waters so
like yeah water um like your own
or like kind of news that's like
dabbing tip off ya like just talk
like how you used to talk let's
get a coke and a hoagie and
go home you talked like that
i didn't maybe not that severely but
yes yeah okay so like just say
something else yeah mike that's quite a
nice bike
that's crazy
i love it but i made it
i made a conscious effort to lose
my accent and how would you do
it would you do like watching eighth
grade but how bibles like yeah if
you watch like the news you know
it's it's and and trusted anybody on
tv make news i got my fake
news jack and if you watch fake
news ah they're using
eight voices and i'm like i'm gonna
do that fake voice
bag of sun chips and wondering when
it's going to be put in the
garbage one hundred percent whole grain more
garden salsa this is a pen goods
no but it is funny when you
see someone doing like the news and
there you see like extra footage where
they're just talking to the camera man
and like ok yeah they're like hey
bro
know what's gonna happen when the principal
exits the school and we will not
know until we see which will be
around three pm of course we will
be waiting here for the moment which
is waiting until three pm or the
principal exit it's one o'clock and we
have not planned this out very well
while i am and the principal from
ferris
mueller is still inside oh let's not
bring him up it's the movie version
of you drag him
dragging me kicking and screaming you got
won't talk about you whether you like
it talk
and that's your punishment it's your judgement
three people talking about you i feel
like our local news the the anchors
have to have like the broadcast standard
speech but yeah it'll be like the
the consumer reports guy can yeah yeah
local axa yeah right yeah and the
sports person is always a little more
like alec
sports you just gotta like the asshole
accent yeah dumb jock exit
whammy
no way he's nowhere yeah yeah yeah
no way he's o m e s
the guy that beat that game yeah
because he memorized the pattern i love
watching that i love it i fuckin
love seeing them have to give all
that my away love winning julius thomas
like fuckin love it i think i
learned to because everyone where i'm from
is a surfer dude so a bra
what's going on it's it's
it's all like this and i grew
up rebelling against that you know so
i i would intentionally say things in
sort of mid atlantic accents in order
to seem smarter than i was and
that's the new and that's how you
got here here yeah and that's how
we met but there you have done
we have met there are those people
who have a different voice than they
actually use like we're like gilbert gottfried
or whatever where it's yeah then you
they're putting on a voice yeah and
at what point is it real and
not it's so interesting there yes especially
in comedy it seems there are many
people that you meet over the years
who sometimes you just want to
i say just to talk normal yeah
right well you know like i want
to have a conversation with it just
be the normal person well when i'm
on mike i sometimes have to overindulge
say because i will otherwise mumble like
i do in regular life so you
know and and everyone saw someone i
just know personally will come to the
show and i'll start off the show
and
i'll be talking they'll be like what's
this voice you're doing you know i
really i've hit on a voice for
the podcast like just being more energized
yeah but i mean that's just performing
who who would be on the on
in this sort of setup that would
be like what's this guy do well
someone who's never heard the show but
knows mean because heard aw show yeah
well that's my point and their shows
business we invite year old high school
friends on yeah maybe i do oh
do that it's bad now you're entertaining
hey lorna you going to your high
school reunion or did you go or
actually did we talk about this um
it's just taking time because my reunion
was du du du dude i'm seeing
doo doo
spank ya my ten year reunion was
to ten touch this fourteen and i
was not a tiny touch this said
can touch oh i bet you've been
ten get my fingers giving choose yesterday
in touch this yeah um i wasn't
invited to my high school reunion in
twenty fourteen you say you weren't you
know my college ran is this year
haven't heard a word about it my
i mean i assume there's a reunion
i it's ten years that i know
i think about there was one for
my high school i wasn't invited to
i don't know that i've gotten in
a long time a formal invite i've
had i've had delivered by a butler
yeah where's my school my high school
is so big and i'm like how
were they going on contact
qt me i don't know how will
do with these village i don't know
somehow my alumni association has found me
though i don't write so they but
my thirtieth is this year i haven't
heard anything not keep one not people
maybe they want to go i mean
like this we're living in a different
time where i feel like i pretty
much know whatever you like to some
extent i could find out what anyone's
doing i would lie
like i don't know who would actually
go ten and twenty my mom once
said something to me like it just
get worse and worse as all your
friends end up dying stuff and and
but so that would be sort of
it but i don't know i would
go because i still go down occasionally
and see my friends from high school
so i like all my friends but
we just i'd rather just get together
with them like i would rather put
on my own party and be like
yeah right the mar with this party
bands and home hometown town ruin my
hometown you know in my liking the
people you weren't exactly friends but were
friends of your friends and then you
could have a whole thing but do
we really doing did you bring really
want to talk to each other
and human ones doing i don't know
i like my curious you are doing
people don't post everyone everyone from my
high school who i don't really know
anymore but i'm curious what they're doing
has a private instagram like oh let
me see let me see your shitty
pictures of you at a bar i
just want to know sick pictures i
see your shit i just wanna know
there's there's a few there's a t
tiny handful of people that i'm still
in contact with at all from high
school not even regular contact but then
people that we have each other's info
you know i'm i've been terrible about
keeping up with that and it's not
it's nothing personal it really is just
that for me especially it's so long
ago now
and we have not been in each
other's lives like you haven't used to
do the ten or twenty right i've
never been to y so i feel
like because i went to ten and
twenty it's like oh now ten years
later i want to see what all
those people are up to again yeah
like i feel like there's continuity there
for me i guess i don't like
i it's i feel the same way
as and that if i wanted to
see
certain people i would see them but
the the people that i kind of
knew in high school are the people
that i just saw because we had
classes together but weren't necessarily my friends
i just feel like i don't know
what that evening would be do you
know what i think what i'm interested
in is knowing i like to know
how like
a story ends or like how it
goes where it's like i have an
idea of ah this person from high
school and then i'm like oh i
would love to know what happened next
for them like right if they were
really popular they were whatever they were
and then like oh and now they
do this job and that's that actually
makes sense because back then they were
kind of into this thing i don't
know i'm just curious how like life
goes
yeah guess i'll be honest it was
really neat that's faith that terrible we
should also i'm at a different point
where i'm like everyone's figuring it out
at this point in my life like
it's yes it seems like people are
starting to find the job they really
care about and then that's interesting to
me but like you know you probably
like who cares i mean the people
that i went to school with and
it was a catholic school and i
feel like you know it people i
would imagine that most of the people
that i knew and hung out with
um that were in my in the
like expanded circle um you know people
are married and they have kids and
they work at gas stations they all
were pumping my gas
i was very nervous for my for
my ten because i was like i
just you know you you think about
it growing up and you there's so
much media related to high school reunion
sounds like it's gonna be it sounds
like it's gonna be this thing and
you're nervous about what people will think
of you and all sorts of stuff
in ah ah and i was and
i was working
as a waitress in a cocktail bar
when i'm in i'm like yeah so
whatcha look huh i'm just thinking of
a song i think i nah yeah
no i hadn't i was working on
mister show but i hadn't about oh
i love that dance i was working
on mister show but i hadn't gotten
an emmy nomination yes so you weren't
like a failure
yeah yeah yeah no but you know
what i mean like when i went
to my college reunion i had got
me i mean right shouldn't that seem
kind of cool right but but for
this one i was like oh yeah
i'm working in television but um the
coolest thing was there was someone who's
one of the popular girls in high
school and whom i was friendly with
so far but didn't really so far
but i didn't
ali know her all that well and
she came up and started talking to
me i'm like so what's been going
on with you and she's like well
i'm divorced i don't have a job
and i went back to school to
try to get something and i'm just
here and she was like so cheerful
about it and i was just like
that what a great attitudes you know
so and it just put me at
ease
and like none of us and you're
like i guess impress her with you
that i nominated for an emmy yeah
so comfortable
have you tried working at a guest
but the twentieth the twentieth was fun
too i don't know i would like
to go to a thirtieth of it
if they have it i just don't
but i went to i like people
i went to high school with he
generally although i hated a lot of
them generally there are some slightly i
like people here's my here's my fear
out to fill manage out there in
new york i feel friends with most
of the people that i really liked
that
time right so it's like that's also
part of it for me is that
i'm like my fear and this this
this is this is because i think
when you move away from home
you are you're not as reminded of
the stuff from that time in your
life because you've you've moved into your
not you're not seeing as you're literally
not seeing as many things that will
remind you right of those days right
so i had dinner with ah a
really close friend of mine um and
he you know we we hadn't seen
each other in years and i was
back in philly for a gig and
um he was reminding me stories and
i know i you'd block block them
out exactly really true for the people
who who would have not moved away
or go back there yeah they remember
more from that time yes they're constantly
somebody but no i was an hour
away i'd forgotten
everything about it to the extent where
i was at my friend's house my
friend had like a really big kind
of mansion out there in orange county
and he had a huge backyard party
in some of our teachers were there
including this one teacher that i had
feuded with um and she and i
was nominated for an emmy at that
point and she and she came up
to me the reason i
mentioned is because she came on time
yes no she came up to me
it was like so hey how are
you so i understand you're nominated for
an emmy so i guess what i
told you that day when i have
that discussion with you after class really
must have ah i really must have
stuck with you and i was like
i don't remember any
thing that you're talking about i don't
really remember much from high school i
walked you ask ah good fans crazy
good for you good for yeah i'm
afraid like if i if i went
to a uni especially now because it's
it's i graduated in nineteen eighty six
and it's so long ago yeah that
i feel like my fear is that
it would be like
that dinner that i had where i
just wouldn't you know they run a
member to say oh the memories that
i have are so there's there there's
so like fleeting words like just scraps
of things and if somebody's gonna remind
me of something that happened and i'm
not going to remember i'm gonna feel
terrible and i think you know what
i would rather do i don't have
an interest in reminiscing
so when i think about going to
one of these things it's not to
talk about what we did the old
days just just talking about whatever yeah
that's one more interested in that like
just seeing how people have evolved sure
but i feel like don't you i
would imagine though the reminiscing is a
huge part of these things yes but
i don't only think of that when
i think think for some people it
is yeah but but there's a lot
of carb
stations where it's just like tell me
everything about your life and you're just
interesting how many town the town that
oh there's a lot of yeah yeah
i'm about to live down miss own
thing god i tell about your divorce
yeah you talk about how california knows
how to party well yeah let's go
for ya let me tell you
or yeah zanzibar what if you went
to here and that was what i
got first see okay so anyway i
moved to california let me tell you
something again i live i yeah that's
part of it is the there's the
dance you're doing sticking your two fingers
up like little gun
oh come on ya knows that a
body in the city of good ol
lots
ah i would love the would just
be yeah i love yeah okay oh
i kona pop by the best i
was like kind of puffed but ah
where have i been these last ten
years i was kind of pumped was
just what i will say though not
having any convoy
perceptions with anyone from high school for
for the ten years other than like
occasionally my friend phil will reach out
on twitter or something and then i'll
go down and see my two friends
every once in a while other than
that like not having any conversation or
any interaction makes me kind of go
oh i'm interested in going to seem
like i used to have facebook and
then i would see everyone and i'm
like i'm not being on facebook
yeah so i don't have any more
so i'm like well i don't know
anyone's doing and i will everyone small
random personal part of my head from
high school and i'll label them joe
like joe
google them and let me type in
joe then i'll get nowhere though because
their name is more common than i
thought sure whatever and then like and
and there's pictures of sloppy joes not
joe you motherfucker
only other luck yo motherfucker but it's
like i can't get my i can't
do my own thing to figure it
out because i have no other word
to search with it well there's no
world is joe
zhao that's something i said or do
just say oh okay so say goodbye
to something right yeah i was like
what did they do that state feels
like a reference to feels like you're
hurting my feelings i don't know why
my friend wanted me to go last
year to his thirtieth because he was
a year above me he was like
on paper
i'll pay for your ticket just come
on down and i was like ah
was it the prices rise you know
all the people because i knew i
knew i'd want to know i'm sorry
but i mean i was injured carey
sure so bob barker
no i mean you know you went
to your school being in drought you
went to your school no well i
don't know why but whose line is
it anyway i think
okay i can't deal with this no
but i being a drama you know
people from all grades or whatever so
i would have known people but i
just i was i don't know if
he was busy too it felt weird
did you go to college scott i
can't remember i went to two years
of ah community college as meaning i
i did two years at cypress college
but then i also went to
two other community colleges because they would
have plays that i would audition to
be in a new admin role at
the colleges so i think i would
like for schools for those two years
and then i went to my acting
school for another two years and we
would have reunions there okay did you
graduate with some sort of no loma
no because in the acting even though
the acting school was part of a
community
college everything that added up would not
have given me a diploma that said
temple university offered me to go right
into the master's program just using that
my almost alma mater to see when
you say almost weaving why did not
i did not complete my studies alright
so you did go there i went
there i went there first
semester one semester yeah and what were
your classes it was like what did
i had a an english class at
a philosophy class i had a mass
class that i was sort of forced
to take oh it was what was
so weird to me was i was
looking forward to when i got out
of high school i thought i'll go
into college i'll be able to to
decide
aside what it is darted out to
study you'll figure it out but then
for some reason i was made to
take a math course and it was
like a remedial math course where it
was it was just a can i
test you on some stuff to persuade
to minus one
it was the the class was a
series of tests the first question on
the first test was add six plus
seven oh noes why do i why
am i hearing i definitely know this
why what does it do to us
protest
sit down
girl see a movie i was forced
to buy an abacus but were they
were they increasing in difficulties so they
just wanted to see where you're coming
from minor way like i went to
i went to summer school for chemistry
and in junior year i was i
was because chemistry was i never took
it what's it what do you do
you pour shit into other shit yeah
and i kept missing i spilled all
over the place so
yeah but there was there's math involved
in chemistry and that was my down
my horse my job how much downpour
and other shit what what is it
actually your think or you're coming up
with ah what is made up of
something okay and then adding doing like
the those diagrams where you would show
like what elements are arranged in a
thing yes there's all kinds of
and it is like salt is made
up with the experiments you know whatever
don't is that what it is not
available
isn't salt in a something we look
it up shit acl google it chef
when i know because i took him
to twice acl my question is do
both of you what were your feelings
about about completing college like did you
care all i cared about you just
i cared about ever cared all i
cared about was drama i
you just love gossip i want oh
no i slept with ya get me
out of here i was liberty i
failed here's the weird thing i came
in having taken a p courses in
high school so i didn't have to
take any math and i didn't have
to take any english so and i
went in going like i want to
get in and out of here
here so i'm going to take way
more ah credits than than i'm allowed
i think you were allowed eighteen or
something like that and i would take
twenty three or something i would have
to go and get permission they were
like well you're obviously smart because you've
taken all these api courses in high
school so yes you are allowed and
then i would fail like every class
because my my
my schedule was i had classes from
eight to noon than i had drama
at two and then i had ah
rehearsals at seven for whatever show i
was in seven to eleven right so
what i would do is i would
go to rehearsal at seven pm and
at eleven than stay with my friends
in the
parking lot drinking beer till five and
then go home and sleep for one
hour wake up go to class for
four hours ah then go home take
a nap in between drama then take
drama then take another nap before before
so i was fucked up the entire
time and i would
often just miss class i would just
sure i was class was the thing
that i would just totally blow off
so i failed art history twice um
i i i failed every single semester
just like bringing home efs efs efs
the only thing that i did well
on was economics because i think it's
related to math which i was good
at yeah so um so and my
pay
parents were just like we can't keep
this going for you we're not going
to keep paying even though his community
college and relatively cheap two hundred and
fifty bucks or whatever they're like you
can't stay at home if you're going
to be failing yeah you're we're going
to kick you out you know so
but i never cared i just never
i never wanted a degree my parents
were always like well what if you
need to
teach i tell you my parents my
mom said to me in two thousand
and four like do you think you'll
ever go back to sky just had
this conversation too i was like what
but my mom was like kind of
not series but kind of like but
you always can and i feel like
you can always be a teacher because
i'm like i don't want to do
that yeah like well also i'm
in my view that i like yes
i checked sign i never bothered me
because i started doing stand-up before i
went to college so that's why i
didn't stay around college so long because
i was like already had a taste
of the thing that i wanted to
do and i was immediately recognized
by the community as somebody who had
promise you know what i mean like
i got good feedback right away that
you're you're an original person and you
have talent and you know all that
so yeah
number one oh boy yeah those out
of body
margie gala fun yeah bills huh e
but after so after i moved out
to los angeles and after i'd worked
on mister show i'd been a cast
member on a sitcom like i never
from the when i started working i
never stopped working and i was home
for thanksgiving one
new year my sister asked me to
think you'll ever go back to college
i was like no i i backed
him on like yeah weird thing because
i always did hold college in high
regard like i was like i want
to have ashore and i care like
my parents really made it so that
i had to have a degree yeah
um and i but i also like
your biggest disappoint
yeah i got a degree yeah yeah
yeah yeah i graduated from colorado um
i have a degree in english from
depaul university oh but i never fucking
use i don't understand the worries that
i would add about ah but i
like i cared about that and i
and because they did i also that
was par
out of it but i was like
i would really like to have a
degree before i pursue this i was
also pursuing him probably doing a lot
stuff while i was in college but
didn't pursue a career professionally until i
graduated and i but i think about
it now and i'm like i don't
really know where i stand on it
because i have so many friends who
didn't go to college and it's fine
and i also understood at the time
that
it would be fine if i didn't
or whatever it wouldn't be the end
of the world but i like still
like really respected the idea of it
and i when i think about like
oh having kids i mean like what
i make them go to college i
sort of still think i would make
them but i don't know i'm not
sure a degree means that much in
certain fields anymore
depending on what and i know they're
really good i agree but i'm saying
like if they were interested in pursuing
like the arts and i i there's
a part of me that thinks that
would be good he want that guy
i will say that i have a
friend right now who is has been
working in the arts for ten years
and wants to get out of it
and wants a certain job and she's
saying like
yeah but i was one semester shy
of getting my degree and i would
need this and so it it has
come up for her yeah and i
have seen it come up for other
people to learn semester and that has
happened to a lot of websites i
actually need one more crushers close yeah
yeah and then i just like but
no cigar right which is good cause
he couldn't you know you got a
cigar now you guys are these guys
close
you do get a cigar is there
a limit on when you are able
to complete no i think you can
do it like anyone no statute of
limitations you can go i actually though
i will say there are so many
subjects that i have no knowledge of
like chemistry for instance i don't know
how it works or what it is
um and a lot of history and
stuff that i occasionally will pay
peruse a local colleges courses and say
i think it would be kind of
fun to take a course i think
what stops but yeah yeah writing a
paper like i just don't want to
write a fucking paper about i already
helped writing my scripts yeah like word
shorter yeah but i'm a bad student
in that if it's not something i'm
completely fascinated by yeah i can't make
i just want to go somewhere where
so not like eighty d it's just
like i don't i i become so
wrapped up in the idea of like
i don't want to be here i
don't realise i just i just want
someone i want to go somewhere where
someone tells me about something interesting and
i go oh wow and i like
leave going wow that's i didn't know
that anymore but i guess
that's books i didn't know that anymore
that's audio i didn't know that anymore
my mommy ah moodle never ever understood
my career or supported it or ever
encourage me in any way yeah um
she was like the kind of person
where i would say are you are
you proud of me and you say
i'm proud of all my children yeah
alright loophole but she was loophole and
he was loophole she lived on the
second floor
my name is ah
i am not proud of you she
after after i lived out here for
years and went back she and it
was it was like at this point
it was clear not only is this
what i'm dedicated to doing yeah but
but you're working out yeah you're just
like i'm actually you know fine
she's she invited me she suggested that
i take lessons yourself uncle
engraved invitation what did you know joel
spence yeah joel spence is you know
is an old friend of my wife
janie and my wash oh no my
wife she told me that one time
non-related sugar
doing william shatner she got child
she got an e vibe from him
an old friend of my my lie
that's that sport for all of us
she got an invite from joel and
she opened it up and it said
joel spence has invited you to go
fuck yourself and she was the only
person though okay that reminds me of
something i may have told him the
shame my mommy story oh but hold
on a second you make it but
i wanna think about it but yeah
thanx think very hard because that's
hard you're going to affect i'll think
about e champion told me she's jacqueline
she suggested that i take lessons in
piano tuning from my uncle toni know
because yeah yeah you're wrong and i
said why would i do that she
said well to have something that fall
back on because piano asra yours fucking
nanos are so much
as popular someone's more popular than show
business probably do better out here than
he did back there exact true he
actually did very well for himself so
don't worry about it yeah yeah he
did i will say my heat dept
my my my father said something nice
to me once when i which was
i think he came out to catholic
radio i've talked about on the show
where
i have my creole and he always
heats he's very he was very upset
with me it's like i loved it
says softly he's begging us to go
eat there oh he wants us to
he wants to see a signed headshot
to be a big chance as i
used to work here anyway since i
used
he was very he was very and
they just have all their former employees
it doesn't matter if you've ever done
moving yeah they met every single that
would be great though every yeah oh
boy everyone's everyone you you your first
day you get a headshot taken they
have a photographer on call twenty four
hours on your last day they make
you sign it
and raspberry i used to work just
pointing in a half yard a bad
idea i would like to go somewhere
where you could see everyone who'd ever
worked there and be really sad probably
just i used to work every single
every mixture has i used to work
every single person could be a pipe
like er da over i'm just imagining
ah that would be great
so he came to visit me and
he was always very strict with me
and very just water on you to
wake you up yes but very disappointed
in my studies and and how i
am with money and he you excelled
at economics ah yes but ah um
so he he came to visit me
at the restaurant once and have have
lunch and then he said you know
what i used to worry
about you but i realize that even
if you don't make it in show
business i realised people like you you
do well at your jobs and i
just think you're going to be okay
and wow yeah i couldn't believe it
oh yeah absolutely my parents believe in
me and so they were like you're
gonna make it no matter what no
they didn't i don't think they always
thought that but as i've developed you
know a career and up to the
point where i know i will be
okay they are like the supportive of
me and like not trying to tell
me
not my mum everyone's home will say
something like you know if you always
wanna do something else you always can't
write because i think she sees the
stress of it as young like i
i've learned not to tell her most
of the yeah you're stressing out yeah
well no but like like where it's
like i don't talk about every audition
because then it's like oh did you
hear about that audition it's like well
no i never hear about any audition
it's just like right yeah they don't
know that like that's a very
pacific thing yes is that you have
to stop telling people about additions yeah
because yeah they don't understand they can't
i mean on the one hand yes
it is let's cool i really like
this page a series of job interview
right you know and if you don't
get the job than the normal in
the normal thing circumstances what you want
char yeah yeah yeah
oh so you don't ever hear if
you don't get audition and then i
have like other things where it's like
you're waiting to hear about something and
i'm like i'm personally stressed waiting to
hear about this thing yeah but if
i tell her that then she's gonna
do and then like did you hear
yet did you hear yet and it's
like every fucking know java got to
know that i feel as crazy as
you do but i it's better just
to give you some good news when
it happens but i think the
part that makes me want to tell
her is the part that i'm like
see i always have some hope going
like yeah even if i'm doing i
do all my little things that keep
me going and i always have something
flowing but like garraway but there's like
a show there's always a big hope
that's kind of there and oh it
all the whole the big hope is
theirs but i'm just saying that lord
lab guess
show what i'm saying like there's california
point which is just that like there's
potential like oh i'm waiting to hear
about this thing and it's like that'll
keep me going in my day-to-day life
but like for me that's good but
for her that's more stressful it's like
it's like for me it's like there's
always some positivity circling like
there could be something that maybe they'll
go away and then something else will
be the thing but it's not the
life for people who like structure right
things like that are you know like
what's going to happen oh what kind
of money like landing yeah all that
kind of stuff is it's very difficult
for people to understand yeah i think
a funeral
my ah the opposite of which though
is i would tell my parents about
things to make them feel better about
my life where i would be like
oh yeah so ah you know this
script i got i made the deal
to write this script and ah they
didn't ended up not making it but
you know like i paid this much
to do everything
cool and and my my mom would
just go like
i don't get how your career works
but i guess it's fine i'm trying
to explain it to you old missions
because she wanted something to point to
i feel like with her friends to
be like look my and my son's
show is out or move right here's
where i totally understand that is because
when i would have to you know
get a new apartment or something new
rhubarb
to have to explain on a form
like how you make a living yeah
it's fill me with so much stress
like no one's going to believe this
like when you see it on paper
it looks like crazy ridiculous you just
show bank statements because i like that's
what i always am led to say
well yeah do that yeah how much
marine lawyer the last time i former
employee anyway
oh well i don't wanna really oh
no i literally nature yeah because i'm
like i haven't you taken i've done
lately i used to do it no
one's calling them if you can say
like i have this much money i
can pay this like whatever it's yeah
how much idea i'll tell you later
we need it later we need to
take a break we'll be right back
hi we're back hi locked me out
of his asshole
well that's where you go during the
breaks mommy i swear i haven't figured
out
scott aquaman nassau during the breaks
oh mommy's and daddy's always daddy's while
i've done those yeah and doi
poor paul sorry but okay no mommy
no life it was father's day or
mother's day is it ah difficult or
is it
no it's not it's not for me
i mean it's it's a combination of
you know they've been gone for a
long time and our respective relationships like
i was close to my mom that
my dad my dad was so she's
not oh right you know i mean
she was not easy she was not
easy but she was
cause i know that she loved me
you know what i mean like we
had we had a lot of great
tools too
i was gonna say yeah but i
held back because i want to have
a chance that she would say she
could say that easily she could say
that she loved me but um but
yeah we had we there were there
were good times with my mom but
she was not she was not easy
but my dad was like so quiet
and remote that it's like he it's
like he's it's the same now as
when he
was alive wow it's really i mean
it really is like that you know
um i would call him i would
call him twice a year i would
call them on father's day and i'd
call him on his birthday and it
was always like an awkward conversation right
so it's almost like you don't have
to do those anymore which is yeah
nice kind of yeah you know yeah
that's so interesting thinking about those relationships
i don't know just thinking about people
going into like like someone who just
like it's like thinking that somebody having
a baby and then being like i'll
be a very detached father i just
say yeah well it's not a father
piss i'm sure another he was rent
to what was expected of you has
changed so dramatically
over the year i also don't know
what changed like it because my mother
and father did not have a good
relationship they must have had it for
a while must have been okay but
but growing up i i don't remember
i never saw them exchange any affection
and they effectively stopped speaking to each
other you know when i was very
young you
no and they would like when they
had to to talk about you know
whatever about the house they would talk
to each other but they it's not
like they would strike up a conversation
you know um i remember like i
remember them doing stuff we would all
do stuff as a family when i
was little but i think like definitely
by the time i was in say
like eighth grade
aid there there they were done you
know right um separate bedrooms and really
yeah yeah yeah yeah which which i
was some people do three-star yeah um
some people do that for the safe
for snoring yeah i'd like and i
well first of all i knew a
couple who did that a while ago
and they had
two separate rooms but then and like
they were decorated totally differently and right
had their own style and then i
was just reading about this on a
blog talking about peoples like marriage advice
or whatever and it was like always
have separate rooms and well all these
people were talking one one person's quote
was all about how they sleep in
separate rooms for snoring and another person
was autistic and then they
they have very specific um things that
who is who is attic was at
utah it was weird it was like
boom boom boom chika
principal oh yeah
ah but this person was assassinated with
the principal from ferris bueller i got
my reasons um
my reasons anyway so they have a
lot of sensory issues and so that
right so sleep next to somebody yeah
but i think it's interesting i mean
obviously your situation was different than those
but to think about people doing it
so that the relationship will work is
interesting like but yeah it sounds like
it was more like i i don't
want to be like why would we
do
let it read this enlightening ticket divorced
um i think it was because of
religion and because of it was just
ah
i think for my mom i was
like well what would i do then
where would i go yeah you know
all these kids and everything yeah you
know i just don't see i think
it was probably like logistically how would
this work it's just such a big
can of worms when you decide to
do that apparent yeah that um
no it's just separate rooms knows getting
a divorce just like it's the unknown
so much of it is the unknown
of like we gotta split up our
money we gotta get yeah two separate
places it's just so much that's i
think for some people it's just like
fuck it i'll just i'll just see
this one out yeah yeah and i
don't know my dad i don't know
if he ever lived on his own
you know any
mean i think he went from you
know his his parents house to the
tv to oh yeah carriage you know
yeah yeah um sort of my parents
yeah my my i mean my mom
i think that she married to get
out of the house you know those
boring them yes
no games what's that marriage sure i'm
not doing anything sign me up yeah
but i as far as like being
a detached dad yeah i can't imagine
like having a baby and not always
wanting to be like oh i love
you i love you and hugging it
and kiss wow but that's babies are
a different thing
and someone develops their own personality and
it's really i don't know what to
do with you now yeah yeah chalk
assassin back saw by bisects don't you
sass me setback passion brac know but
i know yeah i mean you know
i love that i think about that
odenkirk joke and his act a lot
about how his
sun is his worst roommate he's never
ever had it but the trouble is
he loves him more than any other
roommate he's like with older other roommates
it's like god this dick i live
with yeah but for him it's like
eat sucks and i love him so
much um but you know it's
just i just can't imagine like not
every day of that person's life but
then i guess life just gets in
the way where you're just like i
gotta do this shit right yeah you're
stressed out or when you know and
and especially with parents i think with
fathers especially because i feel like my
father was sort of like this where
it was it's just like you know
your expected my
father was away for months and months
you know in the national guard you
know it's just like i go go
take care of shit and you take
care of the kids you i would
take trips right but he yeah he
took trips for fun too they have
a nice yeah
ah for just like weeks at a
time every few years where we go
he would bike across like africa or
like vietnam and do all these like
he's shit he's an avid cyclist he
comes to do it in atlanta all
the time he isn't bike really yeah
that's cool it's like weakness it's like
it's so cool to have something that
your mom doesn't do and it's not
exp
elected to do and he's just like
later yeah and my mom sometimes it's
just her out but they also traveled
together and enjoyed going on crazy trips
like morocco or somewhere interesting and living
my dad is very into when he
travels like living like as close to
me the natives local as you can
really swing in a hotel well depending
i mean usually hotels
but like not being fancy right so
like we went to france when i
was in high school and my brother
and i shared a bed we're both
like oh we're like so mad and
like pillows i'm like oh yeah i
don't want to get horny older like
you don't want to actually touch
someone like you i was like probably
fifteen he was eighteen oh it's just
like my dad like being cheap and
being like yeah your kid lives the
french way i'm like no and then
we went to italy we would go
on these cool trips but then i'm
you know kind of just do it
like on the cheap yeah but i
mean it was i still like think
that was cool and i don't have
any i'm sure that
that you have more interesting memories about
it though because yeah oh yeah yeah
we went to sienna um and my
dad knew um a shot his friend
was a chef who led cooking classes
and would go on a trip to
sienna every wise class so we were
going to italy so we went and
met up with the class and stayed
at this
it's in the countryside of italy and
state in this really cool like villa
or something we but it was so
hot we slept with the windows open
and my brother and i were sharing
a room and then he was covered
in mosquito bites like well it's like
oh some reason they didn't really get
me like i didn't know at both
pillows you put up art know but
i don't i don't know if we
were saying about it that way
that was just one time but yeah
time he was covered in these welts
was crazy but we made pasta with
this class like by hand and then
i cherry off a tree as the
first chair ever had in my life
because you know i have all these
weird things never ate my whole life
and i like i've never had a
blueberry chosen adult i'm sure i've told
you i don't think i do that
spanking
oh she's good or what she said
it or what he said but she
prefaced it so she's okay okay here
are the rule of the ruling coach
kevin referee
australia but i'm pointing definitely in my
head um i had we would pick
cherries off the treaty eat with our
homemade pasta and i had my first
cherry that way and it was like
the best cherry i've ever had in
my life and only by your name
simply fucked it
it's cherry um and i have a
lot of great memories from those yeah
but my yeah my dad likes to
be adventurous you know one of the
best trip memories that i've had was
in cause tremors tremors was costa rica
it's also memories of the movies tremor
movies trevor movies term wellesley is a
serious trouble
um in costa rica you know we
were we were up in the cloud
forest and um it's very relaxing and
of course we got a massage and
you met little kalra ceo all that
kinda stuff but like one when you're
looking through the activities of stuff you
can sign up for one of them
was come help out in the kitchen
and i was like i was kinda
like what and like i won
gonna do this and so we signed
up for it and you go and
the people in the kitchen were like
making lunch and they're like here let's
show you how to make ah roles
campillo and you know they just like
teach you how to make this thing
and then you make it for like
the people were dining there and that's
i mean it just felt like yeah
like stuff like that is yeah that
you wouldn't expect no
i want to relax i want to
yeah have fun or whatever it was
like one of the more memorable yeah
i think those things are true and
then we just like smooshed her hands
together and people's chicken or just like
on i'm horny i would like licked
my hand and touched the yeah we
also were on courses and so we'd
never ridden horseback before have horses in
the kitchen
what are you what are your three
amigo what are you a three of
them ego
you want three amigo are you three
mio when you one two or three
get off
very dangerous horse trip but we were
like we've never been on horseback before
is this cool is going to be
easy they're like very very easy then
we're traversing across streams and share thing
to say very easy yeah no most
natural thing in the world it's not
on the show thank thank you but
he was very great
i was very very fun it's like
it didn't seem dangerous as much as
we were like should we be doing
this i never felt like i was
going to be thrown i feel like
i'd like to try that again i
did it at summer camp i was
on a horse yeah um but i
i've not really had like a strong
desire to do i haven't written one
since i was in high school yeah
i it was fun you guys do
it doesn't it i always remember
being nervous and the last time i
did it i was probably like fifteen
and it was like a trail but
i it's so high up like i
feel very yeah up when i'm on
a horse that that's what's freaking me
out is i'm gonna fall off it
or some why just don't want to
be yeah i don't want to get
like christopher reeve or whatever and i
was sort of like worried about that
but but it was fun i don't
know you know but i guess i'm
a little hoarse yeah
well these might have been on a
minute these might have been slightly more
normal or below the bid i built
a medeco below the pebbles a bird
or the public-health to da da da
da da da da da da da
da da been on the hook
we have to take a break goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye ah
can you fucking believe it
way back can you fucking believe yes
i do believe that we're back back
werber bow okay who has their feature
was a u paul who wasn't oh
no is me oh that's right yeah
we're gonna do we're gonna re we're
gonna use one of our programs begin
three movies
oh there look here that was funny
um we are going to redo one
of our ones from earlier in the
season we're gonna redo switch it and
pitch it oh shit favorite i yeah
we all know how this flown yeah
okay yeah but does kalam
vanya know how to pitch
okay so this is where ah we
is it is it where one person
says it to two people or two
people say it the one person you
guys listen back i think it's that
um one person does the pitch yeah
and then the other are the people
receiving the okay so so yeah grins
nodding think we are doing
and to say to a two of
us will agree two of us will
say to one person will give that
person a title of a tv show
or a movie let's do movies this
time because we did tv shows plus
size so this is this is will
give you a movie title and you
have to so you have to do
the op is do a title that
is the opposite of whatever title it
is
like every word is it's opposite and
then you have to pitch that movie
to us fear for example would be
cube exactly thank you perfectly said but
you can't pitch the movie cube that
already exists while gleaming of it of
course sorting movies not tv shows to
movies yeah you are that right okay
so do we start you who wants
to see we
stars yeah we definitely have to start
at some point
want to be pitched to you want
to be bitch to my this meeting
okay why don't we do got her
the best data so why don't you
pitch to us okay so you go
okay you don't do a title hi
scott so ah and be sad you
have a movie well first you guys
gotta give me the movie title haha
oh
shit watch a movie okay so all
we know you know you're bad and
it's a movie that's ever been made
talk about top gun okay bottom no
no i do i've oh i come
up with the but i was gonna
say bottom i can't get because i
really want the opposite alright guys hey
thank you so much for your time
thank you so much for seeing me
thank you
what's doing well is this by the
way ah it's may amazing so picture
me amazing everyday thing picture studio picture
studio i'm my my martin hey this
is alison i thank you for me
and my email five thirty pm yeah
that's okay you know i figure like
you probably have one last decision to
make before the end that is whether
we have so three minute
it's okay great well i'm here to
ah pitch a great movie called bottom
sword bottom sword bottom soy film
it can't open to glare of content
but if that's what you're into a
can be it's really i'll just change
on my account tommy but my mind
of it will have a queer eye
for the film guy got a queer
eye in your oh okay thank you
i usually say ras hole
wrong i guess you're not cool ah
she likes to wrestle assholes i'll decide
soften em isn't so fun you use
my name like a scientologist i like
them yes meanwhile mark was it martin
martin strike whoa and she's back in
the hole so no bottom saddam sword
okay it's about a
ah and person in the navy oh
the trump admiral doing an admiral in
the navy and it's very american and
he's a real hot dog you know
he likes to take americans hell yeah
so he's the first hotdog to achieve
the rank of admiral of course yes
it's first gonna stick a fork is
this anime and he's on a fork
can easily fuckin along
on and then align and and a
raccoon comes over and tries to hate
it oh and my escape says it
cga iris is played by hulk hogan
this is definitely played by hulk hogan
and those are the top choices along
with edward noisy dog edward norton hands
yeah yes edward norton hands just his
hands were gonna put green screen all
over the rest of his body and
use just
his hands for the hot ramen which
are green yes yeah okay so y'all
so and then we're gonna see gee
i completely everything so the buildings are
cga but the but hulk israel hulk
is real ah in hulk hogan israel
and this i met my first book
is real hook is real i mean
in real life these realist yeah he
big hit
hey big hit so ah basically these
ships go off and they race each
other and it's very cinematic as cinemark
is fuck guys and then at the
end religion oh which religion scientology way
you said scientology like it was a
bad thing though early thing i just
noticed the mo scientology thank you alison
yeah thank you scott okay
well at the very end ah the
hotdog takes out his sword and he
why does he have a sword he
has a sword because he's in the
navy obviously part of his his in
the navy like the y m he's
an admiral he is he he's gay
as hell our bottom a power bottom
and he takes it off any shoves
it up the the bad guys ah
beng ho
lol and goes hey bottom sword okay
so we're gonna talk about this okay
we already have the other movie wherein
the guy ends with the mcnish having
anything else i gotta be honest with
you yeah i fell asleep okay good
so me too so guys you're awake
right now and i can hear our
lot on our plate so i think
the answer is a big fat no
followed by just getting the answers yes
yeah i did it cheese i love
to tease
now of course i was a prank
and i get five hundred points that's
right
very good okay i'm gonna pitch you're
a pitch paul do you wanna do
it or do you want me let's
confer o confer
so we've already used top gun that
was out other than that
wide open field um how bout do
we stick with tom cruise films or
we can do that do you wanna
do a tom cruise themed yeah ah
um there's mission impossible ah the last
american virgin
this isn't me
isn't eating the last american virgin chevy
and google chef he's he's yeah okay
it doesn't matter was eating let's just
say that anyway what's ah no what's
his what's that sex romp comedy that
he did when he was risky business
no he did he did another one
or whatever but i skid losing head
are so loose it yes was it
oozing it i think it was losing
it look up his early film chef
and google chef if you will tom
cruise filmography whatever his early movies i
would say it soon his first it's
after taps but around the time of
risky business you're typing way too many
losing it okay it's losing it let's
just do the last american virgin because
i think okay
okay i've cleared up losing it though
okay great alright the last american virgin
hello hi ray room yes you are
if you know you're looking for yeah
looking for the bathroom oh what a
great ice breaker you shit on our
floor okay so diarrhea too runny diary
okay that's hard to clean up
an idea for a film of course
hope we can ignore the diary on
the floor i have an idea that
i think would be great for your
studio oh right well you know our
studio is a very specific very naish
yeah no that means nice yeah we
only do movies that are either under
one million dollars or above seven hundred
million
so which one of it's under what
was it it was under one million
or above seven hundred or a million
under that you'll save some money okay
yeah yes all right it's millions while
we will spend hundreds of millions on
advertising yes oh okay good yeah so
this film is called the the was
it i'm sorry
the first
um excuse me i don't feel lonely
oh did you do your area
pulse rate you're just gonna plow horse
excuse me oh no i'm talking here
i know but you're also diarrhea but
i'm also talking the fur i feel
like you're talking a lot the first
mexican slots
oh great title i mean i'm like
ah if if you can fill up
ninety minutes just based on that title
oh no that's my you sent me
a perfectly for my little joke i
like to do in my pit sure
so hello i'm just get over to
window because it's really
oh yeah bit more professionally ignore that
i did that
okay okay so we apologise bold thing
to say but here's your meeting meeting
meeting on your terms which i like
i respected i'm a week wow okay
thank you so um it's about should
we do mommy well listen up put
your hands in your crotch and hold
up tight done
so it's about jane the virgin from
the tv show jane the virgin first
but it's mexican because when there's about
us it's a spinoff oh and so
um you know the plot of that
so this movie is a spinoff of
the tv series yes okay i don't
know it's never been done before at
least this is a first
if the plan is to be as
offensive as possible oh so that's why
you diarrhea id oh well yeah that
sets up an important part of the
film close the window down okay you
want to soak it up well now
that i understand the charge on jane
the virgin she's in she's accidentally impregnated
course yes i was
every episode yes no on this show
it's exactly the opposite shah she's intentionally
impregnate not in britain and by many
men yes only not impregnated by many
men okay so they pull up his
condoms or pulls out yeah she pulls
out her vagina out of the dick
and of course um this is something
thing that excuse me i'm sorry you
were distracted and i was distracted by
my assistant chevron
i don't feel safe here i thought
i saw ghost it was just heaven
it was over yeah so sorry i
need to just speak up okay yes
a woman in this era right you
want to weinstein you is that a
weird thing to say no it's not
and that's mine i'm also a woman
so no you're not wait is it
obvious
let me just cut to it who's
doing it disguised let me just cut
to the chase here you're wearing the
good old lady yeah yeah a pantsuit
yeah we're yes no and you're holding
a cane that says i'm a lady
on it yeah
let me just cut to the chase
here i don't think these changes we
need content because i don't think i
wanna give it to you guys this
sounds perfect us up stop i actually
don't think i want to work with
you mom because you me feel so
disrespected refreshing so interesting so i can
i guess when you are interesting
you did di maria on the floor
yeah twice and can i get the
pitch to be fair you also seem
like a bitch that is true i
am a bitch and i am here
to tell you i'm not listening to
patriarchy anymore i want you both go
fuck yourself and take my idea to
studios but everyone wants list me so
thank you very much my diarrhea greet
you on the way out oh well
her diary is going to greet us
we on the way out we really
do that meeting who really did guy
yeah we need movies we haven't bought
a single why did she see see
through my disguise
all right oh you're turning right i
turned to pit lauren do you have
a movie or um yes liking together
one but so did you okay um
my idea is risky business risking business
risky business okay
hey um hi thank you so much
for meeting with me my pleasure what's
your name what's your name again my
name is paul paul kevin you didn't
tell us paul was coming you said
it was a woman named rita you
slut
i to do i'm sorry sorry fair
to shaven in the when i was
in the way that group i was
wearing a full woman disguise oh and
a name tag that said rita okay
no problem sorry to sorry to call
you a slut shell okay no problem
that's why i'm dripping with sweat because
i hurriedly changed my clothes
xd oh okay and the what like
the thirty seconds so did you trick
your way in here did we not
i mean we're no no no this
meetings on the books i just tricked
chevy oh okay that's funny yes you're
pitching us a film yes i am
and what's called it is a drama
it is called safe pleasures safe play
yeah okay interested so it's like some
sucks homeland could save so like something
else yeah i'll say roche all it's
all of these things and more it's
every it's every pleasurable activity you can
think of oh with safety precautions highlighted
before everyone ice tea so i'm thinking
of ah
frisbee golf to people like in movies
they love it then it's in there
it's in there yes and yes before
anyone doesn't i don't like playing it
because i i imagine a frisbee hitting
me in the nose that's right edge
of my nose so people are wearing
helmets like ah medieval soldiers that have
that you know like a little jack
guard yeah yeah exactly oh
oh i like it what's another activity
that people enjoy ah well in my
life um riding under a horse who's
running you grab on gripping around she
was a little hair here you'll like
you cape fear a horse yeah yes
that's in there and it here's the
twist the safe twist
the people are on top of the
horse on a saddle wearing a helmet
i love this i love this um
i don't know something my kids love
to do which is thorpe crab apples
at cars we are absolutely that's slightly
our main protagonist there's several protagonists oh
okay ranging from maine
to the least okay but you love
them all equally right know you love
them according to how much screentime oh
okay yes wild and so our main
potato we're told we love them based
on how much we see them someone's
whispering in our ear that we love
them because we're seeing them more yeah
how do we know we
love them based on their motto screen
absence makes the heart grow colder so
the less you theater people the less
you care about their disclaimer at the
top of the movie that is that
says that or like it just sort
of subtitle like if you saw birdman
the full title of the movie is
safe pleasures absence makes the card grow
colder the less you see any of
the characters
in the movie the less you care
about them thank you for seeing the
movie burn copy right there yeah i
love i love this guy i guy
i love this again i you want
to be with him i want to
be with me is my dream boats
man i want to be at about
i'm not about t-pain
i want him to my friend isn't
doing so well i want emily hey
im losing it i'm friend of you
i please care yam power to make
decisions by yourself yes i yeah okay
with says me daddy guess i'm learning
to get some yeah like full-on kiss
daddy i want to see impact
i'm begging you to kiss my coworker
ooh i like this a lot
i take my car wow rbis face
i mean you've gotta deal yeah
for one dollar oh yeah dollar dollar
option on your idea but we're going
to explore it we're gonna develop it
okay for you shield for you were
a sinner i have to tell my
mommy exactly how this meeting went so
what is like a thing that will
impress her when i tell her what's
the us yeah exactly yeah i don't
think she's
you're presently that i'd be afraid who
it was i'm gonna tell all my
friends about this story and they'll be
impressed i wouldn't tell them about this
story i'm gonna say i've got a
great story i'm not gonna tell you
you can and i'm gonna tell you
tell her we're in development yeah yeah
you have to sign this da so
you can't tell anyone anything
it's a it's it's kind of it's
a very strict mta where you have
to tell all your friends that you're
dead and you also decided this ah
d t m as well which is
it don't tell mommy don't tell mommy
and you can't tell him don't actually
solve a problem for me it also
stanford is easiest for ah down to
masturbate and oh i'm always so
but ah we're we're going to put
no bitch wary in the new york
times obituary obituary so i never die
i want who hasn't died okay to
know betray so understanding people know so
much more pleasant a waste of paper
between the paper hundreds of page but
it's so much cherries why would you
rather read when you wake up in
the morning i'm all these people died
or almost people say my sighting
the thing that makes people think i'm
dead but you're also putting a yo
pictures just to confuse people we haven't
the n d h that people think
you're dead and then the no-bid cherry
clears it up if they're willing to
they're willing to do the re-do go
through thousands and thousands page i also
ask you all were signing things because
you signed my dsr yeah what does
that stand for do not resuscitate
yeah oh sure yeah yeah i mean
with no problem like it's so if
you guys die it will not resuscitate
you yes i have a dnr but
it stands for don't not remember and
i have just a way for me
to forget a bunch of stuff for
my life like remember instance what have
you forgotten well that's what i'm not
sure yeah we'll see it proves it
will you sign this
gdr it's a guns and roses album
because of course i've never met members
of terrorism de la actual row say
dough
you still gotta let me sign this
dear paul keep rockin signed duff thank
you alright deal i think this is
the first guns and roses movie branded
movie yea oh and everyone other six
rod
dan guys we gotta go that's a
lot of time we have we've had
fun i've had fun lauren was fun
although i've gone i don't know until
next week we hope that you have
fun doing whatever you do we love
you we love you love you oh
and by the way i want to
thank i talked about this on a
previous episode
but unconditionally the wayfair company with their
wonderful soft profit bike i just changed
me the m p three i wanna
hear it as the hell out
oh fuck yeah drop the mike
trucking my
yeah
a
so that's how it is wow no
shit downs i love a fake out
free ship in all right i love
that i love that song thank you
wayfair we love you over we love
you and the stuff send us stuff
what do you sell i don't even
wait for you wayfair try not to
tell me let me get all the
way to the shopping cart before you
tell me the thing is no longer
available hey that's a good
which not a feature
uh